ellen is back to work on her show and
day one saw her
pouring her heart out about those
disturbing allegations
that launched an investigation
we know this is a very serious situation
that we're all dealing with
ellen basically called a video
conference for about 200 of her
employees
and at one point she did break down into
tears e.t has learned that ellen led an
all-staff
zoom meeting apologizing to anyone whose
feelings were hurt
she did actually take a lot more
accountability than she has
even if that was to say that she trusted
the wrong people
ellen explained to the staff she was
under the impression that the show was
running smoothly
but later learned it was not ellen did
sidestep a couple of the more serious
accusations like sexual misconduct but
she did tackle head-on
numerous others she seemed quite
disturbed by accounts that
you can't look her in the eye the guests
were discouraged from engaging with
staff
all this to say at the end of that
section of her speech she did say please
look at her please talk to her and
engage
and that's just the beginning we've
learned there is major fallout after an
internal investigation
three senior producers have been fired
there will be a permanent hr employee
at the show so staff can have a place to
go to report any grievances
and ellen's resident dj twitch has been
promoted to executive producer
after six years on the show and in that
role he'll have obviously more influence
over the programming of the show
guests music we talk on the phone we
text
twitch told us in may he thought the
attacks on ellen were unfair
she set up in a high place and people
love to
take cracks when they got time so what's
next be kind to one another
well a source says many staff members
are hopeful as the show preps for its
premiere in 27 days
we're told a goal is to create an
environment for employees at ellen that
is as fun as it is to see the show on tv
if you're on daytime television every
single day i think it's really important
to feel like
there's someone that that makes you feel
like a pal
i think what will change in ellen is
that everyone will be much more aware
sensitive and conscious of other people
who they hire how they treat each other
and what the message be kind really
[Music]
means